how's it going diamond minecraft here
back in again with another minecraft
commentary probably the last one on
YouTube to make this video I'm sorry
okay
I realize I'm about four hundred years
late I've been away okay and I really
want to talk about this cuz I'm pissed
and I'm probably more pissed than I
should be and I'm gonna do my best to
explain why if you don't know what
happened basically YouTube started
unmonitored in people's videos without
any notice now thanks good you've done
it you've really done it yeah alright
listen what we're gonna do here so we're
gonna take away their money and we're
not gonna [ __ ] tell them don't you
think we should just talk to our
creators
that's the YouTube way isn't it why
would they talk to their creators I mean
it's not like we are the core of the
website and I think that's why I'm so
pissed
cuz it's the same story over and over
you can make a change they don't explain
why or what it does it leads to people
being confused and people get pissed off
we'll get to that later but they did
make a statement now and I wanted to go
through it just to kind of talk about
how it affects me and other creators so
basically the type of videos that are
considered not advertiser friendly like
we won't make any money on these videos
are sexually suggestive content
including partial nudity you know what I
might actually be alright so far I
haven't been nude and sexual humor
alright great I'm [ __ ]
alright fine I'll grow I'll have to grow
up alright I can deal with that
number two violence including display of
serious injury and events related to
violent extremism well besides the punch
PewDiePie video I think I'm okay as well
inappropriate language including
harassment profanity and vulgar language
alright well they it's been a good run I
guess I guess I this rate we're just
gonna have to upload a new porn it's
kind of sad but true promotion of drugs
and regulated some senses including
selling and use of such item you want to
buy some drugs check out the link in
description enter the code Puetz and why
the [ __ ] am i making it harder on myself
controversial or sensitive subjects and
events related to war natural disasters
I fully understand that I get that one
that one I can understand you know and
actually you know what I can understand
all of these it's advertisers
spending money it's their money they
spend on whatever the [ __ ] they want
personally I think it's stupid right now
my CPM my average income per view I
might be wrong on that but basically
that's what it is
is it very low my CPM is very low it
should be way higher because obviously I
fit the criteria here my not content is
not necessarily family
friendly it's got a bunch of profanity
with selling drugs yada yada yada
I like how those two are in the same
page you know taking advantage of war
and natural disasters swearing same
thing promoting drugs inappropriate
language same thing treat them that same
thing I don't understand why YouTube
treat everyone on YouTube like they're a
[ __ ] child that's not the case
anymore why are kids the only thing or
finally friend the content are those the
only out people that spend money like it
doesn't make any sense
whatever I'll be fine but there's a ton
of other channels smaller channels whose
livelihood depend on this and you just
go ahead and add this without telling
anyone that's just insane it's crazy and
it seems like they don't YouTube don't
care about their creators that's how I
see this and that's why this pisses me
off because for so long I just feel like
we are treated like nothing like we
don't exist I'm so lucky I am where I am
like no one else would be able to even
say this stuff well actually every one
[ __ ] person ever that did a video on
this probably said nothing every single
time YouTube has updated their website
we creators just have to guess what
happens when they updated their design
we couldn't find anything they didn't
tell us anything I guess we'll just have
to click around and find out there's
never like a update log why is that so
hard [ __ ] me I'm sorry I'm just getting
more pissed I understand that YouTube is
a big corporation it's kind of hard to
get these things across I personally
think YouTube is a great product stop
laughing I really do like compare it to
any other video site it's it's amazing
and we all invested so much time and we
care so much about it and I think the
thing that really pisses me off the most
about this is that it's so easy to do
something about this
literally all YouTube has to do is
update their blog before they update the
website say okay guys this is what we're
gonna do and this is how it actually is
going to affect stuff YouTube has been
treating it as if like well people are
just gonna be pissed and
that's the standard because people don't
like change and no that's not
necessarily true yes people don't like
change but people don't like leave
unless is not understanding something
not knowing what it is and that's why
people were pissed about this this might
not even be that big of a deal but it's
happened one times too many
and if people want youtubers to stay on
their website they're gonna have to
start learning how to do this I'm sorry
I've been doing a lot of rant videos
lately trust me I'm not gonna [ __ ]
about every single thing that happens
don't forget to click on the drug link
in description also vote Trump if you
want you like war you like war just vote
Trump you'll be great
what else was there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry I can't say that one I guess I got
to show my dick as well
all right well dicks out for Harambee
thanks for supporting me when clearly
YouTube doesn't
[Music]